any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
professor allen lightman a really
spectacular writer a thinker an
intellectual
and the author of so many wonderful
books i've read them all
and today alan we're going to talk about
the book that most
influenced me in my life it's influenced
millions of people around the world i'm
talking about a problem book in
relativity and gravitation
let's talk about that for the next hour
shall we
sure that was uh
it's actually one of my favorite books
alan and and it's a little-known book
it's probably your least
read book but it's it's one of my
favorite books of all time
it has a series of books but uh problems
in it
but it's not written in a dry textbook
style in fact it's written in a style
uh that i use to this very day and
people ask me like
how hard is it to generate uh
gravitational waves
and i say well read lightman's book and
you too can generate gravitational waves
when you're on the mass pike or in
i-5 here in california just shake your
fist out the window
and i use that example i've never
forgotten in 25-30 years
alan thank you so much for joining us uh
how are you doing today in these
in these wild times that we're enduring
i'm doing okay um the world is not doing
okay but i'm doing okay i
my wife is a painter and we live on a
small island in maine
uh during the summers and so i'm there
now looking out at some uh
a wood ship path that goes down to the
our dock and then the ocean is beyond
that so i'm very very privileged to be
here
wow that's uh not a place not a not a
terrible place to uh to be
you know confined in in some sense but
uh but of course that
that theme runs through your book uh
which i understand is being turned into
a movie
i want to get a quick update on that
what is the status of that wonderful
book which i've listened to
and read as well uh stars uh searching
for stars in an island in maine what is
the status of the movie adaptation
uh well uh we we have a
a producer uh jeffrey haynes styles who
was the
senior producer of the original carl
sagan cosmos series
we've we've uh written and rewritten the
script
we have uh some associate producers who
are camera people we have a musician
uh zoe keating same last name as yours
she's a cellist
uh and we've done everything except the
filming
and uh my first conversation will be
with the dalai lama
in one month in that book you talk about
explorations with encounters with
buddhism and
notions of time and i think that theme
runs through
many of your books maybe we'll start
there uh one thing i've noted and it
occurs in
in almost all of your books i think is
the notion of the planck time
you know the planck time appears in many
of your books
i wonder what is it about the plank time
that's so interesting to you
is it a fundamental or is it kind of
like a
a coordinate singularity it's kind of an
accident
of of um you know just a coincidence of
numbers or is there something
significant about it you know
does does motion really act jittery
at at fundamental level or is it just an
accident of some you know numbers that
human beings use
well i don't think it's an accident of
numbers that human beings
use just like the number of
particles in a mole uh avogadro's number
is is a real number um
the significance of the planck time is
is that
that's approximately the moment
in the evolution of the universe where
quantum gravity was important
uh that is the the merging of quantum
physics
with uh general relativity
quantum physics of course you know all
of this but i'm saying this for your
guess
quantum physics tells us how matter
behaves at the subatomic level
and one of the the characteristics that
particles can be in two places at once
very very strange uh general relativity
tells us how matter and energy
change the flow of time and the geometry
of space
and the two of them are both
important uh at a
particular early early early moment of
the universe
uh when it was about 10 to the minus 43
seconds old and the reason why that's
significant is because
that is probably the earliest moment
where we can speak
about time and space that at that moment
uh when both gravity and
quantum physics were working together
when the whole universe was
smaller than the size of an atom that
uh time did not behave as we
know it today that is it went forwards
and backwards and jittered around
space the geometry of space was
constantly fluctuating
and uh if there was any
moment in the early universe when you
can say that the time and space
began it would be at the plank time
so it's not just a coincidence of
of numbers i think if we if we could
contact
uh intelligent beings elsewhere the
universe
who were at least as advanced as as us
in science they would know about the
planck time
and of course planck famously said that
science advances one
funeral at a time do you feel that uh
spirituality advances one funeral at a
time
in the same way in other words do you
think you know we almost have to wait
for
you know hopefully to be many years in
the future for the dalai lama or
you know the einsteins or the the people
that uh the spinoza so to speak
to to to pass on before we can have the
paradigm shift in spirituality or
in these kind of existential questions
that you like to consider or
are they totally different i think
they're totally different
uh science i i think is a
is a vertical progress
uh that is uh each
new theory which replaces an older
theories
is a closer approximation to
nature uh whether or not there's an
ultimate theory that needs no revision
scientists disagree about that
and we're talking mainly physics here
uh so when planck said that science
progresses one funeral at a time he
means that
that a theory is uh as
supported for a number of years until
it's found to
conflict with experiment and then it's
replaced by a new theory which is
supported for a number of years until
it's
found to conflict with experiment but
each
successive rung on the ladder is a
better approximation
to nature whereas i think that uh
the spirituality and i would include in
that
all of the arts and humanities along
with spirituality
is more of a horizontal uh
endeavor that is uh plato's
ideas about the best kind of government
and about what constitutes
good and evil are still as valid today
as they were
2 000 years ago and so
uh i don't think that uh and i think
that the
the buddha's ideas about
spirituality and that the cause of
suffering is
attachment to things and too much
involvement with with our own ego
i think that that's just as valid an
insight
today as it was 2500 years ago
what do you make of the the fact that
great men
um in science in theology even sometimes
are not the greatest uh fathers or not
the greatest
you know husbands or not the greatest
you know mentors einstein himself
as you know was not a great husband or
father um
you know the dalai lama obviously is not
a father i once heard him
quoted i've met him personally he's a
wonderful man um
and i once heard him quoted you know
somebody asked him
you know uh your holiness if your
brother were to die
would you not be sad and he said i would
try not to be sad
um i don't think i would be you know i
try to be detached i have three brothers
um they give me a lot of trouble we
fight
uh i have uh you know i have sons
i can't imagine being so detached and i
can't imagine having a full life
a life devoid of suffering as i know
buddhism seeks to be i'm jewish by the
way i'm a practicing jew
but but the point is how do you how do
you reconcile these great minds with the
fact that many of them were kind of
i don't say schmucks as fathers and i'm
not including the dalai lama but
einstein was certainly
not a great father and uh and and and
that's been well documented
yeah how do you reconcile these these
great men with great flaws is it
necessary
or is it you know just a correlation i'm
jewish also and and wagner
the great composer was an anti-semite as
as was t.s
eliot so um i
think that uh that that these are
perpendicular aspects of human nature
um that is the the
the part of our dna
that codes for uh creativity imagination
intelligence
talent i think is it's a different part
of
our dna the controls for our
character and our uh
values and our behavior so
there's no reason why these two why
these things should be correlated while
they should have anything to do with
each other
and there are people who've made
brilliant contributions to
music to literature to science who are
you and i would call them uh decent
honorable human beings
and they're also people who've
contributed to to art and literature and
science that you and i would consider to
be
uh horrible human beings
uh so there's no reason to expect
a correlation as far as i'm concerned
and uh yeah i certainly view that also
you know carl sagan who was you know
ethnically biologically jewish i think
he was a great father
and obviously it's not a prerequisite
that you're
practicing in any way uh he was actually
had his
widow and durian and i had his daughter
on the show
uh last year it was quite delightful um
i want to ask you
a little bit more about einstein but
before i do i want to ask you about uh
the
your the current book the the role of
ego
that is uh that is played throughout the
book and i think
or that is demonstrated throughout the
book at least in the character of andre
linde
who plays a role in my story uh the
story of bicep2
the story of inflation chaotic inflation
and you look at this remarkable
individual
and you and you sort of talk about him
as the man you know who comes closest to
grasping infinity
uh in the modern application of chaotic
inflation
uh you say of him and i quote it's a
beautiful
kind of uh of of passage um
you know that he has this this uh this
this healthy ego
and it is it is something that that
drives him
but it is um you know he has come up
with the most expansive concept
of spatial infinity and you compare him
not you know disfavorably with with the
great and anaximander
and and and so forth and i'm not
disputing that but um
but how do you reconcile these kinds of
things with with the type of science
that he does which you admit
may not be falsifiable and and we'll
talk about that as a rubric for
for for science in a minute but but how
do you balance that kind of ego that it
takes to do
great novel science with the humility
that you have to have that nature may
never
afford you the opportunity to be proven
wrong
well i don't think it requires humility
to think
that you might be proven wrong
um
uh i think that you can be a great
scientist and either be humble or
arrogant i think that again you know
going back to
whether you can uh be
a talented person and not be
morally good i think it's the same thing
that
i've i've known great scientists who
are arrogant and i've known great
scientists who are humble
uh but it certainly does not take
require
humility to to do science
uh
i uh you might remember that
that when uh we're speaking of einstein
einstein now that when his theory of of
of
gravity general relativity predicted
that light would be deflected by the
gravity
of the sun or any massive body
which which is not true in newton's
their earlier theory
and uh the british scientist arthur
eddington
went uh to test that during an eclipse
to measure that
and uh sent a telegram to einstein
saying that that his prediction of his
theory was confirmed
and i think someone asked einstein
what he would have done if the
experimental result had disagreed with
this theory
and his response response was then i
would
have felt sorry for the dear lord
because the theory is right
that's right and uh you know that brings
me to my uh
to another theme of today's conversation
which is you know the proliferation
of that three-letter word god uh that
appears so often
in uh various regimes in physics but
specifically
in cosmology and particle physics you
know alan uh i don't know about mit but
you know i
i never noticed you know in the
condensed matter you know uh
experimentalist hallway you know i never
noticed them talking about the
you know the god instantan or or the the
super conductor god or you know
it's always in the in you know the god
equation it's always in the god
particle the theory of everything is the
gut mind of god according to stephen
hawking
what is it about our friends and and
some of my best friends are string
theorists right
that that gives this impremature by the
way do you think they really believe
i had michio kaku on the show uh he
claims to be agnostic
i really think he's functionally
indistinguishable from an atheist in
other words
he doesn't go to the same church that
richard dawkins doesn't go to
uh he was raised buddhist he uh became
or no his parents were buddhist he was
raised episcopalian
uh presbyterian or a pescopane i can't
remember which one but um
but now you know he just he doesn't
practice and he kind of believes in the
spinoza god of einstein
uh but you know i kind of view that as
almost a cop out and i taught freeman
dyson that as well
in our many conversations what do you
make of this and and you're a humanist
and and and and you talk about that
quite frequently
but um you know sometimes they view that
as kind of like a shorthand like i don't
want to commit
when they say they're agnostic um is
that just like a safe way of
of of not having to commit to to being
an atheist uh so that
maybe you know that won't impact book
sales as stephen hawking's editor used
to say
or do they really not believe or not
have enough evidence to
say one way or another that god doesn't
exist
yeah well of course i don't know what's
in the mind of of
uh michiko kaku or
uh freeman dyson um i don't know what's
in their minds
uh when they say they're agnostics so
but but i would speculate
that they're atheists as as i think you
are
suggesting and of course in
in the the world that we live in today
um
it uh it's it's
unpleasant uh socially
to say that you're an atheist uh
richard dawkins of course has made his
name on saying this atheist and i don't
agree
with much of what he does not because i
think his arguments are wrong but but i
think that he is
condescending and dismissive
of believers and uh
so i i respect
people who who believe in god i have
many many friends who are
quite smart and talented and creative
who believe in god
and i totally respect that
but i i do think that that many people
who say that they're agnostic
are really atheists and they're just
trying to be polite
and that's my speculation
[Music]
um one thing that is in hebrew the the
term is ain't self without
and is god himself and god is the only
entity without without
a spatial extent without temporal extent
without pre-existing creator and again i
consider myself this isn't about me the
show but i consider myself
a practicing agnostic you know in that i
am
searching i'm looking i am not ruling
out but i'm also not you know
uh i am i am not about i don't wear
yamaka i don't i keep kosher et cetera
but i i think if you tell somebody from
the beginning that there's no god as
dawkins does
you establish as you say dismissiveness
divisiveness and you might even
undermine your own case against
atheism you know for atheism and i think
hitchens and others did a much better
job
well dawkins not only says there's no
god but he says that people who believe
in god are stupid
part ways with him on that
yeah and he also said things you know if
you raise your child as a christian it's
like child abuse because no one's born a
christian
anyway we're not talking about him but
in in judaism uh there's a notion of
of you know god's infinite being in your
conversation
in a probable improbabilities and talk
with linde about infinity
now one thing i've had a lot of
discussions uh for example
sir roger penrose i'll put a link to it
somewhere in the in the screen
here uh is about you know the notion of
singularity and that
we're always told we need a theory of
quantum gravity
because the singularity in a black hole
or at the origin
of time in the big bang which he doesn't
believe in as you know
um features this kind of transition from
infinite temperature infinite density
infinite
pressure to something finite but i don't
know of a single phenomenon
in nature that is infinite i know of
things in math that are infinite
but i don't know of any physical process
that can transition
from infinity to to finite and he gives
you an answer in the book that's
reminiscent as you quote
uh very astutely as you know you know
hilbert hotel
which we'll put a little diagram you
know people checking in and checking out
but um but he doesn't really answer the
question uh which you pose but i think
it's a very good one
have you ever gotten a good answer to
that question of how do you gut from you
know
zeno was asked this question in
different form 2 500 years ago how do
you get from an infinite quantity of
something to a finite quantity of
something in a finite time does anyone
have an answer to that
well you're you're not when when
cosmologists
talk about uh the infinity
of spatial infinity
uh what what they mean is that
you could go get into a spaceship that
went
uh at the speed of light or even faster
uh well we can't go faster and you and
and you would never
come back to where you started
um at the universe is
is is finite um
eventually you would come back to where
you started if you could if you could
freeze it
at a given moment um
so i don't think the question of going
from
from infinite to finite ever comes up
and that kind of understanding
what's meant by cosmologists
we're not uh each thing within the
universe
is finite but if you got into
a spaceship and traveled you know at the
speed of light
you would you would keep going and keep
going and keep going and keep seeing new
things
um uh except for
uh the the the the fact that
uh discovered in 1998 that the universe
appears to be accelerating so
you would you there would be a limit to
how far you could get
um in terms of seeing new things
but uh if you could freeze the universe
right now so that it was not expanding
not accelerating just
freeze it then if you got in a spaceship
and went at the speed of light
you would never come back to where you
started you would just keep seeing
new galaxies new things and that's what
what is what the cosmologists mean by
a universe is infinite and extent
so so i i think that we won't have to
how to go from the infinite to the
finite
lindy himself has been been a remarkable
you know maybe it's the
uh you know it's this it's this
indomitable russian
spirit and and uh which i love yeah uh
and have always been enamored of um as
a russian font my wife was asking me
yesterday how do you say you know
there's like cynophile and there's you
know japanophile but is there a word for
russian file i don't know
maybe you know but um but at some level
you know these russians have this pretty
natural
you know gift for for confidence and i
remember a debate that he had with
martin reece and steven weinberg
and they were talking about the
multiverse and they were saying you know
what level of credulity and confidence
do you have
would you bet your life would you bet
your dog etc
and you know and the famous joke is that
you know
linday would bet uh martin martin reese
who's been on my podcast and
he said he'd bet his dog and uh linda
said he'd bet
uh his his life and weinberg said he'd
bet uh
both his life and uh i mean he'd bet
linda's life and and reese's dog
um on the existence of the multiverse um
you know
and i i did a video once about this and
the nation nature of faith and and to
what level do you really have to have
faith
and you end the book and you end that
that chapter about
you know it is kind of this most
beautiful and kind of the closest we get
to you know the improbability of
infinity and
and so forth but you know at what point
do we do we really let the beauty
of equations substitute for you know
evidence and and you speak about direct
god you know the only time dirac
ever mentions god you quote in the book
you say you know god is a mathematician
of a very good
order um and that's the only time dirac
ever talked about god you mentioned that
in the book
um and so and he also said it's more
important that your theories be
beautiful than they'd be
you know subject to experimental
verification so i guess linde and him
would get along well
but you know what's your opinion alan
should we you know
are we relying too much on popper are we
are we putting too much faith in the
paparazzi as my friend leonard suskin
says
the the the desire for beauty and our
laws of nature
has turned out to be an excellent guide
to finding the right laws
so so just on a practical basis
it's worthwhile for people like dirac
uh paul dirac to uh
and and uh ed
with string theory to look for
beautiful mathematics that has paid off
in the past as a practical matter but
science ultimately is an experimental
enterprise and ultimately any theory
no matter how beautiful if it conflicts
with experiment
has to be discarded and a prime example
of that was
uh something called parity conservation
which is the idea and this was very
prevalent in the 1920s 30s and 40s
that everything that you see in a mirror
exists in nature uh when you look in a
mirror you you reverse
right hand and left hand and the
the statement of parity conservation is
that the
right-handed things that they're an
equal number of right-handed things and
left-handed things in nature
uh that the mirror image of nature also
exists
in other words and it's a very pretty
idea that is why should nature have a
handedness why should things
more things be right-handed than
left-handed
and as you know in the 1950s
i think it was there were some
experiments
done that showed that
nature in fact does distinguish between
right-handed and left-handed that that
the mirror image of nature does not
exist
in the same quantity
and that this beautiful idea is wrong so
so then everybody had to go back to the
drawing board and start revising their
theories to agree with this new
inconvenient fact and uh
you know even einstein uh despite his
statement about
the bending of light i think did put a
lot of stock
into an experiment and even suggested
some experiments of his own
uh so uh
it's true that today theoretical physics
has sort of backed itself into a corner
where we believe in in these things like
the multiverse
and string theory that have uh
beautiful aspects to them and of course
strength theory is very beautiful
mathematically
even though i don't understand all the
mathematics of it
uh but we have to be willing to
discard those things if they're
experimentally proven wrong the problem
is the rub is
that we will probably never be able to
prove string theory wrong
and we'll probably never be able to
prove the multiverse wrong
will probably never be able to test
those ideas
and that's where the real problem comes
and then you have to ask the question
if we're if we're doing things in
science
that we can't test
if we have theories that we can't test
is that really
science or is it theology or philosophy
and you know we can debate on that
question
that gets into the question of what is
science
my uh theme and i can't resist putting
in one sound effect if my
listeners will indulge bill put in a
baseball sound effect here allen
and that is i think it's very important
to get points on the board
and i talked to your crosstown rival
kamran vapha
last year and i said you know tell me
a falsifiable prediction that string
theory could have been wrong
and he said well string theory has a
prediction that the mass of the electron
should be
essentially it was you know a couple
thousand or million times greater than
the planck mass
or you know a less than the planck mass
and a couple of billion times less than
the plaque you know so some
range that's pretty big you know plank
mass is pretty large
um but but anyway it was a prediction it
was a wide range it was like me
saying you know i weigh less than you
know 80 tons
and greater than a microgram you know
which after covid
you know i put on the you know the
coveted 90 no no i haven't put on quite
that much
but my my viewers will know you notice
undoubtedly some
gain in my in my girth but but
nevertheless i saluted him because alan
it was putting points on the board it
was showing something that could have
been wrong it could have said
you know it's greater than the planck
mass and then you could just rule out
string theory right
um on the other hand you have people
like kaku
who will say well the g minus two
anomaly you know that's
uh that was you know that's a prediction
of strength here i said really i don't
recall anybody
you know uh a month ago saying don't
worry next week this result's gonna come
out even though
brookhaven had the results 22 years ago
nobody did that and he said no
no you have to tell me the um the
initial vacuum conditions
of string theory then i can tell you
which
uh instantiation of the string theory
uh you know landscape is and i said
that's not my responsibility
and he said well how many you know how
many uh solutions to maxwell's equations
are there
i said there's an infinite number but we
have boundary conditions from
observation
and so my my implication you know to
strengthers is
look for the low energy limits look for
the ways to connect with observations
that you already have i mean
you know when people tell me they need a
future you know hadron collider
you know squared i say well you know
what you do have
that you know that god or you know the
multiverse has given you it's given you
this this collider
that takes these 30 solar mass you know
black holes and crashes them together at
half the speed of light you know what's
wrong with that
can you do something with that to test
your theory of everything and and
usually they say no
say that one of the problems with string
theory is that
that there are a zillion different
possibilities or vacuum states to use
your language
to start off from so they're 10 to the
500
power something like that and so
that's one of the reasons why i can't
make any any predictions because there
are too many
possibilities uh
and and maxwell's equations there's only
one
route of equation so that the two are
not comparable in any way
mm-hmm um going back to your
crosstown rival at harvard um
uh the late great stephen j gould used
to speak about
non-overlapping magisteria he used to
say
that religion and science were separate
you know but equal
i want to apply that to writing and
science
and you do both exceptionally well um
should we view those as non-overlapping
magisteria i usually say to my friends
you know i joke around i say it should
be a moral obligation
to communicate science if we get paid by
the public allen i feel that
you know people should do what you do
you know and communicate to the public
whether for profit or
for you know to write and think in
public because without the public you
wouldn't be able to do what you do i
wouldn't be able to do what i do
and so not giving back in a way the
public can understand they can't pick up
prd
and understand it so what do you feel
about that is there a noma
aspect that well no you're good at
science just stay in your lane
or should we be encouraging young people
to do what you do
so well at mit should that be a model
for the rest of the world to adopt
including here in san diego and
elsewhere well i think that
there should definitely be some
scientists
who communicate with the public
and explain science well to the public
and write about it
and not only a a factual accurate way
but in a
literary way but i don't think that all
scientists need to do that
um you know if if if every scientist
wrote a popular book
nobody would have time to read them all
or even a small fraction of them
so i think it's efficient
for the community of scientists to
produce
several people who are
writing about science for the public but
it's certainly not a moral
responsibility for every person
to to do that that's that's my
when i say every person i mean every
scientist
i certainly think that that every
scientist
should be sympathetic to this activity
and there was a time in the early 1970s
when uh very few bona fide scientists
were writing about science uh
lewis thomas and stephen j gould in the
area of biology
um let's see
jim watson and uh richard feynman
in the areas uh well jim watson's
biology richard feynman and steve
weinberg in
in physics uh
there was a period of time then where
were
writing for a scientist to write about
write about science for the general
public was considered a waste of time it
was
uh you were looked down upon as a
scientist
by the scientific community um
i think that that era has passed uh i do
think
that that every scientist should respect
those people who are spending part of
their time or even all of their time
writing about science and talking about
science for the public
yeah and certainly uh you know sounds
like you were
also influenced very much by carl sagan
who you met uh
i understand at cornell during the
sabbatical you had
uh for a couple years um he was a great
influence i regret never having met him
but
um but he was a huge influence and i do
know his
his widow has been on the show and his
daughter's been on the show he's a great
influence and of course i think he was
unfairly penalized for outreach um
famously not getting into the national
academy
despite his incredible scientific output
creating you know new fields
astrobiology and and so forth and
not the least of which was his outreach
to the public that reached billions in a
way that even
neil degrasse tyson who's in some ways
uh protege of his who's also been on the
show i'll put a link to
his episode somewhere around here um i
want to get to uh because i know you
only have
another 10 or so minutes i want to talk
about a book that made a huge impact on
my life
when it came out in 1993
i was just a beginning graduate student
and that's einstein's dreams
and that is a a wonderful delightful
fantasy book
and and that's so you know just i
remember reading i was like how can a
professor at mit write a book like that
and i wonder first of all if you're
familiar with the works of mit
graduate um uh jenna levin and
and her wonderful books uh her fictional
books uh
you know that she seems to be kind of in
that mold of like
you're super confident also you know a
relativist
like you um what is it about the you
know the water on that side of the
cambridge uh
river uh that that gave you the liberty
to kind of write a fantasy
a book about uh these different
modalities
these different ways that time can
manifest itself and and which
you know what what gave you the
confidence to do that you you were you
know this is 30 years ago almost now
what gave you the confidence to write
that book at that time in your career
yeah well that book didn't come out of
nowhere
uh i mean as a child i
was interested in writing and science
both
and i wrote a lot of poetry as a child
um so i was interested in trying to
somehow pursue
a career in both the arts and sciences
from a young age
uh so i was i was writing and publishing
poetry and small
magazines in the 1970s and early 80s
and i began writing essays
about science in the early 1980s
and uh as i wrote more essays i began
uh twisting them to include
fictional elements the essay is a very
flexible
literary form you can be informative you
can be poetic
you can be personal and i began
putting fictional elements into the
essays that i was
writing and eventually
uh that led to einstein's dream so there
was a long runway
for einstein's dreams the runway started
when i was
12 years old it didn't have anything to
do with being at mit
it just had to do with with my
long-standing interest
in both the sciences and the arts and in
philosophy
i've always been interested in
philosophy
when i was in college i was debating
about whether to major in philosophy or
physics
i took a lot of philosophy courses and
philosophical ideas have entered and all
of my
writing uh which is
well i think it's apparent in in the
book einstein's dreams
and i have a question um from my
audience
about that wonderful book uh and it
relates to
a topic that we had discussed earlier
and that's
sir roger penrose's past guest nobel
laureate
um a past guest on the show of his
conformal cyclic cosmology
there's a lovely quote and this is from
james r one of my listeners
uh there's a lovely quote in einstein's
dreams which made me wonder suppose time
is a circle
ending back on itself the world repeats
itself
precisely endlessly what do you think
about
um sir roger penrose's ideas and and um
obviously those came out actually
afterwards you talk about his ideas
later in this kind of uroboros
uh in other books that you've written
but um what do you think about his ideas
now
uh 22 years 28 years after
einstein's dreams uh have you you know
if you wrote einstein's dreams too would
uh sir roger penrose
i wasn't aware that the penrose was
advocating a
cyclical universe um
i'm i'm i'm aware of his work in
cosmology and i'm aware of his
his of his book the emperor's new mind
in which he says
that the
mental phenomena have have a quantum
mechanical element to them
but i don't know anything about his
advocacy of a cyclical
universe uh i i know it's his his
his work on twisters yeah he's a real
he's he's a he's a a phenomenon i mean
he's he's one of a kind he's
he's one of the you know maybe the
greatest
mathematical physicist in the last
century
yeah he's uh he is a phenomenon he turns
90 this august i'm
delighted to be able to speak at his uh
birthday party
virtually he's become a friend um so his
model i i'll i'll put links to the
you know to the interviews i've done
with him up here in the video when it
comes out
um his his model came up really
in contrast to andre linde and the work
of
inflation which he views as you know i
guess i can't imitate him
but this is a form of you know rubbish
as the british might say in that
you know this this spawning of the
multiverse at least in spatial
infinity uh is very problematic and as
you know he has said and my friend paul
steinhardt has said you know is
undermining of the scientific method and
that it basically makes
you know falsification and and the 400
year old
practice of science dating back to
galileo you know impractical and
and uh and so forth we don't have to get
into that we've already spoken about it
but he has these
unending cycles that he calls aeons uh
uh uh during which the very low entropy
conditions of the universe can be
um gobbled up and and the universe can
be started off
cyclically um without a bang without a
singularity
um and it can repeat many times over and
he claims there's evidence for it i've
actually
uh fought with him about the evidence
that he claims is kind of confirmation
bias
and that's kind of fun to do to to
challenge somebody who himself
is an iconoclastic um character
challenging the dominant orthodoxy
i want to ask you uh getting back to
einstein's dreams what of those many
scenarios of time
of of of universes of different ways
that things can play out
um how did you know which one kind of
resonates
with you for me as a parent it's
impossible not to think
about the universes you know where where
you know children and parents are
interacting in these
ways either they're there's a barrier
and they cannot interact and there's
there's a mournfulness and there's
there's a there's a soul in that book
it's so painful and i couldn't have
appreciated that allen
as as i didn't as a as a 21 year old
graduate student and now i do reading it
again
it's so delightful by the way if you're
an audible member um and i hope someday
audible will hear this and
and sponsor me but anyway uh but you can
listen to it for free
um it's on audible i believe if you're
an audible member so
i urge people if you've read it already
please read it again listen to it again
i think alan will get the residuals no
matter what you do
but uh but the bottom line is it's such
a delightful book but
are any of those more resonant with you
now as an author i know as a reader many
of them resonate more with me now than
they did 30 years ago almost
do any of them resonate more with you as
the author 30 years hence
well there's some of them that resonate
more with me as a human being
and those are the the worlds in which
we try to live in the present the
present moment is important
and i think that that since i've written
that book 30 years ago
uh since that we've had the
the advance of the internet uh smart
phones google all of those things
have come about since i wrote that book
and and it's made the world faster and
faster
uh the speed of the the pace of life has
always been regulated by the speed of
communication
as community communication has gotten
faster and faster and faster and faster
in 1985 near the beginning of the
internet is it was
about a thousand bits per second and now
it's a billion
bits per second is the speed at which we
can transmit information
and we we just we just rush around
far more than it's healthy for us
checking off
items on our to-do list and
we we cut down our efficient use of time
to
10 minute units of efficiency you know
if it takes your
printer more than a minute to
spit out five page pages you get
impatient
wait if you have to wait in the doctor's
office longer than 10 minutes you get
impatient
so we we we need time to slow down
i mean we need the permission to slow
down
and and just pay attention to where we
are
at the moment and what's happening at
the moment i think the pandemic has
helped a little bit in that regard
because it's forced a lot of people to
slow down
but looking back on that book now
30 years ago
the the worlds in which
the moment is precious
are the worlds that that are most
meaningful to me
now
yeah and me too i get emotional thinking
about it alan
um i you know also having young kids a
little bit older kids you know
intermediate kids
uh listening to it and i'm guilt i feel
so guilty he's telling you this
but when i listened to it the second
time i listened to it at 2x speed
and i i knew you'd probably be mad at me
but but on the other hand i can listen
to it two or three times and i can
i can jump around and and i and i just
feel like
um it's such a gift that you gave to the
world
um because you're also giving permission
to to geeky nerdy physicist and
you know the joke about scientists how
do you know a scientist is outgoing
because he looks at your shoes when he
talks to you um and and most of my
audience are brilliant and they
they love it but it's a book that a real
scientist
a real scientist can get into and you
can grapple with these notions of
causality of reality
it's an and but you'll also be um
it's a literary gift and and i want to
thank you i i've wanted to tell you that
for
nion 30 years since i was a graduate
student but i appreciate it more as a
parent
and being mindful and thinking about
meditation but also listening to it at
2x speed
anyway alan i want to uh we only have a
few more minutes i want to ask you the
questions i ask all my guests from
billionaires and brainiacs to nobel
prize winners
mit professors i think mit and harvard
are battling it out
along with ucsd for the most frequent
university
uh employees to grace my uh
my show and be and honor me with their
presence um so alan i sent you the
questions if you're willing to answer
them
i would be so honored and some of them
one of them relates to the title of your
book so that'll be the last one
first one is um a question i asked my
guest and that is
what would you put on your ethical not
in your material will
your ethical will what wisdom or values
do you most want to articulate to future
generations as an inheritance
and it is some piece of wisdom that
you'll give to
your biological heirs but also to your
ideological heirs of which i consider
myself one
do unto others as you would have them do
unto you
i think that uh religions uh
differ greatly and and their values and
morals
but i think most agree on that i think
that that statement first appeared
in isaiah in the old testament
and that would be what i would pass on
that's funny you're the um you're you're
not the first
uh secular humanistic jew
to quote uh from the old testament the
tanakh uh one of the first was andrewian
who quoted from mika and she said act
justly
love mercy and walk humbly but she
admitted the last three words
with your god and uh and we laughed
about that but
uh but that's okay uh that's okay okay
the next question has to do
with a great scientist and communicator
uh
very much reminiscent of you alan and
that is arthur
c clarke not a jew nobody's perfect i'm
just kidding i'm just kidding i'm just
kidding
um what material object or knowledge
would you put on or in your monolith so
you've probably seen in arthur c
clarke's 2001 a space odyssey
there are these monoliths that are built
by extraterrestrial species
which are eventually discovered in the
solar system
uh and this is not too dissimilar from
feynman's cataclysm question so
what thing would you put on a monolith a
billion-year time capsule
to be discovered that's to be an
emblematic representation of what
humanity achieved
well i wouldn't i would not put any of
our mathematics
and science because i would assume that
that would be known
uh by other civilizations um
i would put some of our art and i would
put
uh some of beethoven symphonies
uh in there because because uh the
artistic expression
of a civilization is unique uh and i
would put music because it does not
require a language
uh to translate it so um i would put
some of beethoven's
symphonies on there i'm number i'm uh
particular about
symphony number nine uh
i think that or the maybe the moonlights
but that's what i would put
and the time capsule wonderful and
uh yes i when i asked anne jurian that
she said oh i already did that with the
voyager golden disk
she put her brain waves on it along with
uh world
world music so that was the first
example of world music in human history
being recorded so i hope e.t can
understand a phonograph okay
the last one relates to probable
impossibilities
and that is sir arthur c clarke's third
law which states the only
way of discovering the limits of the
possible is to venture a little way past
them
into the impossible i thought you'd like
that that's the origin of the name of
this podcast
alan what aspect of life seemed
mysterious
and maybe even impossible to you but now
that you've had
the benefit of life and experience you
tell that young version of yourself to
give you the courage to go into the
impossible
i haven't thought about this one
um
well i think something that
that uh that i couldn't imagine
when i was a young person
was being a parent
make making a baby with another person
and then being a parent uh
i think as much as we read about that
and talk to other people
that we don't really understand what
that is
until it happens uh
it's it's of course your your parents
mentioned that here but it's
it's one of the most glorious aspects of
of
living uh of course people who don't
have children uh
often have good reasons for that so i'm
not uh
you know discounting that decision
uh but that's something that i
couldn't possibly imagine when i was
a young person
yeah but as you already said even if you
don't have a parent even if you don't
aren't a parent and don't have children
you can still pass on your values
your wisdom to ideological uh errors
alan i want to thank you so much for
being a mentor remotely to me whether
you wanted to or not
thank you so much and have a wonderful
rest of your day thank you brian
thanks for inviting me and having me on
you
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
if you enjoyed this episode without
lightman i know you'll love
the episode i did with david kaiser who
is alan's
neighbor down the hall at mit and if you
enjoyed
any of these episodes i know that you'll
want to subscribe so click here
and don't forget to leave a comment what
you think is alan lightman's greatest
contribution to
date